[Music]
qualcomm ai research
is hiring for several machine learning
openings
so please check out their careers
website if you're excited about solving
the biggest problems
with cutting-edge ai research and
improving
the lives of billions of people
[Music]
today we got to speak with one of our
heroes in machine learning
professor max welling it was good the
questions were
really fantastic actually and i've never
done this with the three of you but
having a team of three people asking
questions is really it's a good idea and
of course you're really smart people
knowing what you're talking about so
that went really well i think
needs three brains to match yours we
asked max
some of your favorite questions from
reddit hi max
when will you be changing your last name
to pooling
max has pioneered the discipline of
non-euclidean
geometric deep learning so what is
actually geometric deep learning it's
the idea
of performing deep learning or machine
learning more generally but let's say
deep learning
on data that is not euclidean in some
sense so
not a nice change structure for audio
or a planar structure for images
but perhaps a sphere or a graph or
something more exotic like some kind of
manifold with arbitrary curvature
you might want to model weather patterns
or social interaction data
there are many types of data out there
that are non-euclidean
actually if you've been playing with
graph neural networks then you've
already been doing
non-euclidean or geometric deep learning
so to make this work you just need to
abstract some concepts
so the euclidean distance or your
neighborhood
it becomes a function of connectedness
just like on a social graph
am i connected to john does john know
bob
it's simple as that actually this kind
of abstraction works in many areas of
mathematics which max will get into
today as well as making neural networks
work on non-euclidean data
the other thing that max has really
pioneered is this idea of recognizing
symmetries
in different manifolds so in this blank
slate paradigm that we have now in
neural networks
we're essentially wasting the
representational capacity of the neural
network because we're just learning the
same thing
again and again for example in a fully
connected neural network
we would have to learn the dog in the
top right corner and the top left corner
because there's no translational
symmetry and it was exactly this reason
why convolutional neural networks were
so powerful
because they introduced this concept of
translational weight sharing
so you had this filter that you could
shine over the entire planar manifold
and it meant that those parameters could
be reused
and you could learn concepts in
different parts of the visual field
it was an incredible breakthrough
imputing this kind of knowledge into a
deep learning model this is called an
inductive prior
it means that we can take some prior
knowledge about how things in the world
works
and we can impute them into our models
it makes our models more sample
efficient
and it makes them generalize better when
it comes to sophisticated inductive
priors
max welling is the king when we think
about ai and its capability to actually
help
us to enrich our lives we know we need
to first help machines see
and understand like humans do take this
drone collecting data in 3d
or this autonomous vehicle with cameras
covering a 360 degrees view
current deep learning technology can
analyze 2d images very well
but how can we teach a machine to make
sense of image data from a curved object
like a sphere and because we want this
processing to happen on the device
itself
for reliability immediacy and privacy
reasons
how can we achieve this in a power
efficient manner
it turns out we can do this by applying
the mathematics behind general
relativity
and quantum field theory to deep
learning our neural network takes in
data on virtually any kind of curved
object
and applies a new type of convolution to
it we can move the shape around and the
ai will still recognize it
this is just one example of the exciting
research we're doing at flokomaya
research
to shape ai in the near future anyway
it turns out that these symmetries are
absolutely everywhere
if you wanted any further proof of how
useful these kind of equivariants and
symmetries and manifolds can be
look no further than the recent
announcement from deepmind
alpha fold it will change
everything deepmind solves
50 year-old grand challenge the game has
changed so proteins are the structures
that
fold in a given way the result of this
year's competition came out
and they looked something like this
namely
every entry here you see is a team
participating
in that competition of protein folding
prediction
and there is one team which is
deepmind's
system alpha fall 2 which completely
dominates all the others to the point
where the problem is now considered to
be
solved by the way if this is not a great
meme template
i don't know what is just saying just
saying
they say a folded protein can be thought
of as a spatial graph
this here attention based okay so
i'm going to guess uh for sure
that they've replaced this convnet with
a transformer style with an
attention layer or multiple attention
layers
i would guess this is a big transformer
right here
so there was a really interesting
article that came out called alpha fold
and equivariance by
justass dupodas and fabian fuchs
i'm so sorry fabian i don't know how to
pronounce your name but it does sound
like a swear word
justice and fabian etau comment on the
announcement from deepmind and they said
in short this module is a neural network
that iteratively refines the structured
predictions
while respecting and leveraging an
important symmetry
of the problem namely that of roto
translations
at this point deepmind has not yet
published a paper so we don't know
exactly how they address this
however from their presentations it
seems possible
that part of their architecture is
similar to the se3 transformer
what's the se3 transformer
lo and behold our friend max welling has
had his hands
all over it so uh in the abstract it
says the se3 transformer
a variant of this self-attention module
for 3d point clouds and graphs
which is equivalent under continuous 3d
roto translations
equivariant is important to ensure
stable and predictable performance
in the presence of nuisance
transformations of the data input
right by the way you might be wondering
what se3 is let's have a quick look at
the wikipedia page
we are getting into group theory which
is quite an abstract concept in
mathematics but
the euclidean group which is se3 it
talks about all of the the symmetries or
the group transformations that can be
applied
to euclidean data to preserve certain
properties
namely let's say the euclidean distance
between two points well these are
things like translations and rotations
and reflections
very interesting that you can kind of
abstract one
level up in mathematics and that's what
group theory is the other comment i want
to make is that all of these folks are
independently amazing i've watched
presentations by most of them so that
there's fabian fuchs
daniel warrell volker fisher fantastic
by the way when we look at
fabian's about me page he's a machine
learning phd student at oxford
university
his research topic is learning invariant
representations
simply put where most of deep learning
is concerned with finding the important
information in an input
he focuses on ignoring harmful or
irrelevant parts of information
this can be important to counteract
biases or to better leverage structure
in the data structure and the data
that's interesting
that's quite a cool point actually
because if you think about it you could
naively
if you're doing a vision classifier you
could naively just look at all of the
pixels and what they are
or if you're being smart about it you go
one level up and you look for the hidden
structure in the data
and that is precisely what he's talking
about things like
the symmetries that are inherent in
pretty much every type of data
okay so one last thing deepmind released
an official
powerpoint deck on alpha fold too
and it talks about they're on a long
term mission to advance scientific
progress
now here are some of the protein
examples now they
specifically call out inductive biases
for deep learning models where this is
exactly what we're talking about so
clearly convolutional neural networks
are one such bias which has the
translational weight sharing
it talks about graph networks and
recurrent networks and indeed
attention networks which is very much a
generalization
of pretty much all of the others they
say that they are putting
their protein knowledge into the model
so physical insights are built into the
network structure not just the process
around it
and these these biases reflected their
knowledge of protein physics and
geometry
and you can see here that there are
residues in a protein so they're
modeling topologically
which residues are connected to which
other residues in this kind of 3d space
they specifically call out here on the
structure model page that they are
building a
3d equivariant transformer architecture
so anyway if this doesn't motivate you
that symmetries and manifolds are an
exciting idea in deep learning
i don't know what will so clearly max
has been in this game for a long time
now
back in 2004 with kingma he invented the
variational bayes auto encoder
it's only recently that well relatively
recently that max has been
focusing in on deep learning clearly
like any other field
also machine learning is subject to
fashion
right and so there is a five to ten year
cycles where people get really excited
about a certain topic
either because the theory is very
beautiful or it just works really well
i started in the biographical models and
independent component analysis was the
talk of the day
and the support vector machines and
basically non-parametric methods and
then
became bayesian methods and
non-parametric bayesian methods and now
it's all about deep learning
so what you see is that the field is
subject to these sort of
fashions and i think it's fine because
we zoom in a new very
promising tool and then we work it out
and we get the most out of it
max is a vice president at qualcomm so
clearly he thinks that computation is
going to be absolutely critical
for the future of artificial
intelligence but having said that he
also thinks that we need to be more
efficient with our hardware
tomorrow than we are today that's just a
reality that we all have to accept
so the more compute we throw at it the
bigger we make our models
somehow the better they perform and we
don't know precisely why that is but we
do know that they will
use increasingly more energy to do the
computations for us
and at some point that's just not a
viable economic model anymore we'll see
a continuation in making deep learning
and machine learning more energy
efficient
so there's a really interesting
interplay between priors
experience and generalization
we want to have machine learning models
that generalize really well to things
that they haven't seen
during training if you move them into a
new
orientation or in a new situation in a
context
and that's what we think of when we say
artificial general ai which means like
not just something you train on one
specific topic and then you ask it to do
that and it does it very well but if you
then move it
into a new context it just completely
fails that's narrow ai
so humans are clearly much more flexible
if we learn something in one
context and then we get put into a new
context that we've never seen before so
we can still do very well and so we want
our agents our artificial agents also to
have this property
max is also a huge proponent of
generative models he thinks that
generative models might be the future of
artificial intelligence so
funnily enough i think max and carl
fristen that we had on a couple of
episodes ago
i think they would see eye to eye
basically what everybody else in the
scientific community does which is
write down a model of the world which we
call a generative model which is
how do i imagine that the world that i'm
seeing in my measurement
apparatus could have been generated by
nature we all have the matrix going on
inside our heads
we are running simulations of reality
and we're kind of integrating over the
expected value of those simulations
this is just something that we do all
the time that seems to be the real trick
for
intelligence at least in humans so our
ability
to generate the world max also thinks
that we need to be learning
causal relationships in our models
causal relationships have this really
interesting property that they
generalize better
so max comes up with this wonderful
example of
a certain color of car in the
netherlands
might be associated with a higher
accident rate but that probably wouldn't
generalize very well to other countries
because it's just a colloquialism
whereas male testosterone levels that's
a causal factor
and that's going to generalize far
better to other countries
so try to figure out what the true
physics of the world is what causes what
and if you have this causal structure of
the world
you understand much more about the
actual world and then if you move it to
a new context you can generalize a lot
better in this new context
at this stage max has bet on so many
winning horses that
you've got to wonder how the hell does
he do it so we ask him what his secret
is
it's incredibly hard to predict what
will become well known
sometimes you just happen to be working
on something that takes off like a
rocket
when we did things like vae or graf
neural nets it didn't feel at all like
this was going to be a big hit
when we read some of the research from
max's students
we were just blown away sometimes we got
to just remind ourselves that these are
fairly young folks that are in their
early 20s that you know
they've just come out of university how
is this even possible
i've been very blessed with being able
even with my industry funding to
provide this level of freedom
to the students and i think this is
really key so one of the things we asked
max
was how does he select his research
directions
one of the interesting things is that
he's a physicist right so
many of the things that he's been doing
are straight out of his operating
playbook from the physics world
so things like symmetries and manifolds
and even quantum
like symmetries have this this deep
feeling right symmetries
pervade basically all theories of
physics and they have this
profound impact on how you formulate the
mathematics of a theory
especially when it becomes almost
mysterious right quantum mechanics is
almost mysterious
how on earth is quantum mechanics
possible the fascinating thing here as
we discussed on our gpt3 episode
is that many of these roads actually
lead back
to computation itself how does the brain
compute things also feels like a very
deep question right how do we
even compute things what is computation
even and does the universe compute its
solution
what does it mean to be predictable can
you predict can you compute
faster than the universe can compute one
of the key concepts that we talk about
in the show this evening
is the bias variance trade-off nothing
comes for free
there is no machine learning without
assumptions you have to interpolate
between the dots
and to interpolate means that you have
to make assumptions on smoothness or
something like that these prior
assumptions will
help you transfer from one domain to
another domain
one of the topics we've been discussing
a lot on machine learning street talk
recently
is this notion of how far can we take
data driven approaches
will they take us all the way to agi or
is it just like
building a tower and trying to get
closer to the moon
perhaps we could generate more data with
data augmentation
or even a simulator perhaps we could use
data more efficiently with machine
teaching or active learning or some kind
of
controller on how we train the model but
ultimately how far can we really go
the big question in some sense over time
is
can we simply take the data-driven
approach
and extend it all the way to agi
so max tells us about all the different
schools of thought
in the ai community and of course one
interesting school of thought is
the likes of gary marcus and waleed
sabha that we had on the show a few
weeks ago
these people think that we need to have
an explicit model of the world
and then there's on the other side which
is more the classical ai
sort of community which is no no that's
going to be ridiculous you will never be
able to do that you really
need to imbue these models with the
structure of the world
in the show max tells us where he's
placing his bets
but we're not going to spoil the
surprise so as we said before max is
extremely well known
for creating these inductive priors and
putting them into machine learning
models
helping them generalize better and be
more sample efficient
the whole endeavor of machine learning
is
defining the right inductive biases
and leaving whatever you don't know to
the data
if you put the wrong inductive bias into
things will things can actually
deteriorate we talk about hinton's
capsule networks
they tell you well we'll just keep the
abstract nature of what we want which is
some stack of things that transform
in some way that we can vaguely specify
and then
we ask it to learn all these things we
talk about professor kenneth stanley's
greatness can't be planned book and also
sarah hooker's the lottery paper
the thing that both of these ideas have
in common is that
they posit that we are locked in by the
decisions of our past
and i do feel very strongly that as a
field we need to open up
so we we should value original
ideas much more than we currently do so
professor ken of stanley has a
fascinating take on this
he thinks that we should be treasure
hunters we should find
interesting and novel stepping stones
that might lead us somewhere interesting
he thinks we should do this in all
aspects of our lives
so we all want to monotonically increase
our objectives and what we should be is
treasure hunters
yes science should be about exploration
not exploitation
how do we extend this to peer review in
science ironically having a consensus
peer review
encourages group think and convergent
behavior
if we genuinely want to have an
exploratory divergent process
we should almost optimize for people
disagreeing with each other in the peer
review process
i think the reviewing in our community
is far too
grumpy i'm continuously amazed when i
read these old papers from let's say
schmidt uber and like the first rl
papers that
just came up with a bit of an idea and
then they had a bit of toy data and
writing that's a paper and
and it's cool there's a dichotomy
between on the one hand
having a stamp of approval having a
paper published and presenting about it
and on the other hand having a
continuous stream of research which is
peer-reviewed online and with some
accountability
yeah we i think we really need to
disrupt the field a little bit
quantum machine learning is a bit of a
mystery
to most people i feel including myself
and even though i learned something in
this conversation paradoxically
it's more of a mystery than before the
conversation
crucially max thinks that quantum
computing will
hugely impact the machine learning world
in the future
so you can think of quantum mechanics as
another
theory of statistics in some sense right
essentially
quantum neural networks have nothing to
do with
particles necessarily or physics it's
applying
the math behind quantum mechanics to
machine learning
and you building neural networks as
layers of functions
of these quantum operations
that forward propagate some signal uh as
max describes
really nicely in this conversation this
is the counter-intuitive part which is
you can have a probability for an event
or an amplitude for an event and then
for
you have an amplitude for another event
and you would think that if there's two
probabilities for that event to happen
then the
the probability that events should grow
but in quantum mechanics they can cancel
and then the probability is suddenly
zero that the event happens
so this seems bizarre but nature has
chosen this theory of statistics anyway
i i really felt like an eli 5 here
instead of calculating with
probabilities
you calculate with something like the
square root of probabilities and thus
events that can only stack
in classical probability theory can all
of a sudden
cancel each other out and that gives
rise to really
interesting math we talk about max's
recent quantum paper that just got
released
and so that was a paper that we recently
pushed on the archive which is a
quantum deformed neural networks which
we basically first say okay what if we
would
take a normal neural net and implement
it on a quantum computer and then we
slightly deform it
into something where states get
entangled so
by doing it in this particular way we
could still run it efficiently on a
classical computer
what this paper here did was to build a
particular type
of neural network of quantum neural
network
that can under the correct assumptions
be simulated efficiently on a classical
computer
but also once we have a quantum computer
it can release its full power basically
if you want to do classical predictions
does it actually help to build
a neural network that can run
efficiently on a quantum computer that
can do these predictions
much better can you write down
maybe even normal classical problems
more conveniently
in this quantum statistics i found the
conversation with max to be
extremely helpful here and he does a
great job of
explaining what's going on max has
another exciting paper app
probabilistic numeric convolutional
neural networks it's a paper by mark
finzee
roberto bonderson and of course max
welling and it
looks at what you can do with computer
vision models if you move away from the
assumption of
discretely sampled pixel grids and move
to a continuous representation that's
more like
what an actual object in the real world
projected on a screen
behaves like the observation is
when we write down a a deep learning
algorithm let's say on the foreign image
then we sort of treat the image as
pixels and we think that's the real
signal that we are looking at
but you can also ask yourself what if i
remove every second pixel
now actually i have a very different
neural network but should i have a very
different neural network or what if the
pixels are actually quite randomly
distributed in the plane just some
random places where i do measurements
maybe more on the left upper corner and
and fewer in the left lower corner
the predictor should behave in a certain
consistent way
and so of course then you come to
realize that really what you're doing
with the pixel grid is sampling an
underlying continuous signal
so to get away from this assumption of
this discrete even
sampling they use these objects called
gaussian processors to model the data
and a gaussian process it's basically a
universal function approximately
like a neural network but it gives you a
measure of uncertainty and
the reasons you might want to do this
are many but in short it allows you to
average over every possible model that
describes your data and gives you a
better result
in doing so you can start to do really
interesting things
like sub pixel sampling or work with
very sparse locations
but in order to do that you need to
reconceptualize a lot of the familiar
operators
that work on our linear algebra
representations such as like the
the convolutional translation operation
of our weights
the way they got around this was super
interesting so
there's a very interesting tool which is
called the gaussian process
it basically interpolates between dots
but in places where you don't have a lot
of data
you create uncertainty because you don't
know what the real signal is
what does it mean to do a convolution on
this space the
most interesting way to describe that is
by
looking at it as a partial differential
equation so they reframe this
transformation
as a differential equation that could
just be parameterized calculated
out in a closed form and directly
applied to the parameters of the model
that means you don't need to like do any
sampling or anything like that you
literally just calculate this thing
apply it it will be worth going into the
differential equation stuff by itself
but it gets very complicated very
quickly
needless to say it generalizes to not
just translation but also things like
rotations and scaling
but the way that they really did this
was by finding very clever
representations
boiled everything down to normal
distributions or almost everything could
just be done in closed form which
things have been done with gaussian
processors in the past but they're
typically computationally expensive so
if you can do all these updates without
constant recomputation then
that's a huge computational advantage
the paper does some really cool things
some of the benefits are now that first
of all of course you can work on
a unstructured set of points doesn't
have to be a grid
and you can even learn the positions of
those points so you cannot direct
the observations in places where you
really need to do
observations in order to improve your
prediction so it turns out that all of
this can be remapped
back onto the quantum paradigm i must
admit i'm almost gutted that i didn't
study physics at university
physics seems to be one of the most
robust scientific disciplines
and the folks are just so smart because
it's really really difficult
and what i notice is that it's very very
difficult for external folks
to get anything published in the physics
world but there's an asymmetry the
reverse isn't true
loads of these physicists are coming
into the machine learning world and
they're just implementing all of these
things whether it's symmetries manifold
topology
chaos it's really really interesting to
see this unfold
we also get a take from max about gpt3
and so you say gpt3 isn't very good
maybe but it's a receding
horizon right i had a chat with my old
colleague from microsoft elia karmanov
about 18 months ago he introduced me to
max welling's work
it absolutely fascinated me ever since
and guess what elia left microsoft and
he went to qualcomm
hey tim how's it going ilya it's going
great how are you
i'm good different country different job
different
universe it seems but i'm doing pretty
well ilya and i
used to be work colleagues at microsoft
uk
and i left microsoft about a year ago
and actually you left as well didn't you
elia yeah we had a joint pack
it was like you have to keep both of us
or
we leave indeed now um ilya and i made a
youtube video
just over a year ago and it was all
about maxwelling's work with taka kohen
uh all about symmetries and and
manifolds and this work was hugely
inspiring for me
how did you discover it i discovered it
because my colleague matthew
and i whom you also interviewed and you
should follow up with uh robert we were
iclear and we saw tacos
talk about spherical cnns which was a
bit late
already into his work which started with
group equivalent convolutions and i
think both of us just thought it was
really cool it was our favorite talk for
the day
because it was so different and it felt
like it was setting up a different
stream of research
it wasn't necessarily about chasing sota
it was just about really
improving taking what makes convolutions
great and making them even better
and that was awesome oh amazing well we
made that video together on machine
learning dojo and i must admit it was
hugely inspiring for me
and i reached out to max welling about
two months ago and he actually came onto
our podcast we interviewed him yesterday
but
yeah this it all came from you and you
know you introduced all of this stuff to
me
and i've been going through some of
max's work with some of his recent
students and it's just incredible it is
because he came from the physics world
and all of this knowledge that he has
around quantum and
symmetries and topologies and manifolds
that's his operating playbook and he's
just taken it into the machine learning
world and he's just been executing on it
max is involved in a lot of papers
as you would expect and a few of them
are really fascinating
yeah one of the things we spoke about
was just how he nurtures his phd
students
because some of these papers are just
incredible and presumably these students
have gone from
nothing to producing that level of
research in a very short period of time
but presumably this was one of the
reasons why you decided to
apply for qualcomm yeah it i i was
chasing something that was
publishing papers in the field of
computer vision and it's one of the
places
in europe perhaps zurich is another
location where you have this kind of
research
i thought it was extremely different and
a super interesting
research area so to speak to get into
fantastic
and what are you working on at the
moment we have just submitted
actually our paper to cvpr this morning
the deadlines in a few days so that's
pretty good i think
and then maybe after that as well we
have a few more uh topics in video
basically uh self training
how to improve representation learning
it's a mix of knowledge distillation and
still training and then also we have
some interesting work with
radio signals so it's like video in the
sense that it's
from that we extract the spatial and
temporal signal but it's
extremely different to video and that
also makes it super fun
amazing when i was discussing machine
learning with ilia
at microsoft we were fascinated by 3d
convolution on your networks and i3d and
video action detection and
i know you are working on 3d
segmentation and a whole bunch of cool
things like that
but anyway i would love to get you on
the show in the next few weeks to talk
about some of your research and
for those of you in the comments if you
want to have more from ilia let us know
are you going to give us a demonstration
of your front lever
okay single leg when ilia comes on the
show properly we're going to be doing a
front lever competition
that's pretty good so not only is ilia a
specialist
in machine learning he also absolutely
smashes it in the body weight game
uh no that wasn't smashing it that was
after a climbing session it's actually
really cool i i met this guy here who's
a calisthenics instructor
called solly and he just started
climbing and yeah so we met up and we
went climbing this morning
and he was crazy good as you would
expect and he gave me some tips on my
front lever as well he was saying i
should work more on the tucked instead
of the single leg
uh so hopefully you'll see much better
than that in the future
amazing amelia thank you so much for
coming on the show we look forward to um
interviewing you in in a few weeks time
yeah thanks for having me and thanks a
lot for interviewing max i'm like super
excited to
see that in a few days anyway i really
hope you've enjoyed the show today
this has been such a special episode for
us because max welling is
is literally one of my heroes so um
anyway
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments we really
do actually we're getting
so many amazing comments in the comments
section so keep them coming
and we will see you back
next week welcome back to the machine
learning street talk youtube channel and
podcast
with my two compadres alex stenlake and
yannick culture
and today we have someone who doesn't
really need any introduction at all
clearly one of the most impactful
researchers in the ml world
and has as near as makes no difference
40 000 citations
he's on the executive board at eurips
he's a research chair and full professor
at the amlab university of amsterdam
and co-director of the cuva lab and
delta lab max welling
max is a strong believer in the power of
computation and its relevance to machine
learning
which is one of the reasons why he holds
a vice president position at qualcomm
he thinks the fastest way to make
progress in artificial intelligence
is to make specialized hardware for ai
computation
he wrote a response to rich sutton's the
bitter lesson but essentially agrees
with him in the sense that one should
work on scalable methods that maximally
leverage compute
but max thinks that data is the
fundamental ingredient of deep learning
and you can't always generate it
yourself like an alphago which amounts
to an interpolation problem
much of max's research portfolio is
currently based on deep learning
he thinks it's the biggest hammer that
we've produced thus far and we witness
his impact every single day
he thinks that agi is a possibility and
it will manifest in a forward
generative and causal direction there's
a really interesting cross-pollination
story here max has a physics background
he did a phd in physics
he knows all about manifolds and
topologies and symmetries and quantum
and actually this has been his operating
playbook he's brought all of these
incredible concepts in from the physics
world
to machine learning now there's a
fundamental blank slate paradigm in
machine learning
experience and data currently rule the
roost but max wants to build a house
on top of that blank slate max thinks
that there are no predictions without
assumptions
no generalization without inductive bias
the bias variance trade-off tells us
that we need to use additional human
knowledge
when data is insufficient i think it's
fair to say that maxwelling has
pioneered many of the most sophisticated
inductive priors and deep learning
models
developed in recent years an example of
an inductor prior is the cnn
which means we can model local
connectivity weight sharing and
equivariance to translational symmetries
in gridded vision data this is imputing
human domain knowledge into the
architecture
it makes the model significantly more
robust and sample efficient
assumptions are everywhere even fully
connected networks assume that there is
a hierarchical organization of concepts
and even further assumptions about the
smoothness of the underlying function
we're estimating
max and many of his collaborators for
example taco cohen
took this idea so much further they
introduced rotational equivariance
and then they built models which would
work extremely efficiently on
non-geometric curved manifolds
meshes or even graphs max wants to
reduce the need for data in deep
learning models
increasing the representational fidelity
of neural networks subject to
discretization and sampling errors
and improving the computational
techniques to process them more
efficiently
max has recently put out two new papers
quantum deformed
neural networks and probabilistic
numeric convolution on your networks
which we'll be talking about today
anyway max it's an absolute pleasure
welcome to the show thank you very much
tim for a very nice introduction
it almost sounded like it's not me but
it was a lot do you
feel that this is this it describes you
not maybe accurately but
do you feel like there's a parts of your
work that are overly
well known and there may be parts of
your work that
you wish would be more well known
it's hard to say it's overly well known
because of course it's very enjoyable
and
you can make a big impact but what i can
say is that it's
incredibly hard to predict what will
become well known
of course if you could predict it you
would only write papers with like
gazillions of citations when we did
things like the vae
or graph neural nets it didn't feel at
all like this was going to be a big hit
and some of these things are being
singled out and they
fly and precisely what makes this
these papers fly is you know that's a
big puzzle in a way
and some other papers you can be very
proud of and it takes so much time to
actually get
published it's a huge uphill battle you
think why do the reviewers not
understand better what we really want to
do here
and then yeah and so they i guess
there's a lot of good work which
disappears into oblivion
and from many people and yeah
it's mysterious but anyway your hits
definitely seem to be more than your
misses
you're a prolific researcher yourself
but you've nurtured some of the best
and brightest minds across in not just
deep learning but like the wider machine
learning field
how do you consistently do that is it
fantastic mentorship or is it more
finding the right spark in a student and
nurturing that
yeah that's a really good question and i
should say that i've been extremely
blessed by all these fantastic students
right from the beginning but i do think
there is something
to nurturing talent so i think what
doesn't work
is to basically tell to be very
constrained to a particular topic
sometimes you see this happen if you
write a grant proposal and then the
grant proposal is about topic
a and then really the student
starts at topic a but figures out after
a couple of months that they don't
really like topic a and they want to
move on to b
and it's just very painful then to say
no no you cannot do that you have to be
doing a and so i've been very blessed
with
being able even with my industry funding
to
provide this level of freedom
to the students and i think this is
really key so the other thing which i
find really key is that the relationship
you have with the student is very
important first of all it changes over
the years which is also very beautiful
so you start off with much more guidance
and towards the end
you should actually not be doing any
supervision you should just
having a conversation at that point on
equal footing
and you see about halfway through a phd
like it's like a flower that opens and
then
now they get it suddenly right now they
get it and they go
and they have a wild huge interesting
ideas in all directions and they can
write all these papers and stuff so
that's a beautiful moment when that
happens and the other thing i think is
that
i i think of supervision as nudging in
the sense that
i have a big a lot of experience and
where is
where is the interesting stuff to be
found right where
is the next wave that we can get people
enthusiastic about what are the
important questions to address in the
community and things like this so
that's where my experience lies now i'm
not
doing a lot of coding myself in fact i'm
just all doing almost zero coding which
i
regret so that's life and the other
thing is that even in terms of math
it's limited right i write but most
maybe two pages of math to verify
something or to compute something
quickly
but not like a lot of math anymore i
just try to keep up with literature
mostly and the students do though so
they do the hard work literally so they
really should
they should do all that work and it's
this interesting relationship where you
have a
discussion where you say i think you
know this is an important direction an
interesting direction and here are some
other things which are connected to it
very intuitively right so you may want
to look there
and then a good student will just pick
up these ideas and we'll run with it and
then come up with new ideas and then
you could say it is maybe be careful
about this direction don't
don't go too deep maybe this is more an
interesting direction stuff like that
but
even there i've learned to be very
careful
and if a student comes up with a good
idea and
intuitively i think that's actually not
a great idea this is going to be a dead
end
that i'm not going to tell the student
that very soon
i'm just going to certainly leave the
student about a month
to explore that idea for sure and i've
been surprised
right i've been surprised and basically
it turned out it was a great idea and i
was wrong
and so i've been very careful with these
things too so i feel it's a very careful
dance between the student and the
supervisor with not
too much direction also it's a very
personal so some students like more
direction and other students like less
direction but
i think it is a bit of an art i've i've
learned
to appreciate that this is a little bit
of an art to have the right type of
relationship with students yeah but of
course it's all about them
they are the ones that need to shine in
in the end after four years and they
need to get the good jobs and become
famous
in terms of that guidance and
specifically what you said with respect
to
this direction might be interesting
these are the interesting research
directions is this something that you
just have to develop or do you have some
general
can you give some high level patterns
that you've observed
throughout the years where you see
recurring things
and and you say ah that's another one of
those
probably like short-term hypes or yeah
have you observed some general patterns
there
yeah so there's two things right so
there's some things where i think
why what is the big deal why is
everybody chasing this particular
direction
so that's can you predict what the crowd
will follow
that's one thing seems pretty hard the
other
one is to find directions which maybe on
longer time skills are
impactful and interesting and for the
second one
it is deeply intuitive and it's very
hard to figure out precisely what it is
what features there are but for me
i have to get a sense that there is some
something very deep going on that i want
to pursue like uh
for instance so i clearly in physics so
if you can think about gage
symmetry like symmetries have this this
deep feeling right symmetries
pervade basically all theories of
physics and they have this
profound impact on how you formulate the
mathematics of a theory
and so there's something very deep about
symmetries and and about you know
manifolds and
doing things on curved spaces and so
that's i could sort of naturally drawn
into this thing not now it's more
quantum mechanics and
there's something very deep and
especially when it becomes
almost mysterious right quantum
mechanics is almost mysterious how on
earth is quantum mechanics possible
if you dive a little bit into this
phenomenon of the two-slit experiment
where you have these individual photons
which which go over two paths
and if it's a wave that's perfectly fine
they can interfere with each other but
now
these photons can go one by one and
somehow they have to be aware of this
other possibility that they could have
taken
to interfere with that other possibility
i just think that's crazy
what's going on here and so i'm
naturally drawn into sort of these kinds
of
mysteries in some sense yeah and there's
plenty more and the other one is also
computation clearly right how does the
brain compute things also feels like a
very deep question right how do we
even compute things what is computation
even and does the universe compute its
solution
what does it mean to be predictable can
you predict can you compute faster
than the universe can compute and so
there's all these very deep questions
about computation as well that you're
going to ask
but there's a mixture between things
that are
attractive in that sort of mysterious
sense there's something very deep that
needs to be pursued
and things which are also highly
practical which is sometimes
it's also a lot of fun to work on
something that where you can actually
make a big impact
for instance speed up mri imaging
with a factor of 10 so now suddenly you
can
actually both image and radiate cancer
at the same time which could have a huge
impact
in the future right now and feeling that
level of impact
is also quite exciting i think amazing
so i wanted to um frame up some of the
work that you've done around symmetries
and manifolds
it's absolutely fascinating the
prevailing idea is that we are wasting
the representational capacity of neural
networks because we're essentially
learning the same thing
many times and your work absolutely
pioneered this
starting with sort of rotational
equivariance on on cnns and then moving
on to meshes and graphs and and
different types of topology it's
absolutely fascinating but
philosophically the modus operandi in
deep learning is this blank slate
idea this idea that if we look at data
and nothing else
then we can learn everything we need to
presumably not in a very sample
efficient way
transformers seems to be going in this
direction in the natural language
processing world that we just ingest
infinite amounts of data and we can
learn everything we need to
and we spoke to a good old fashioned ai
person walid sabha last week and and
his argument was that the information is
not in the data
he was arguing that we have a kind of
ontology or knowledge built into us
which we can use to
disambiguate information that we receive
so
fundamentally speaking do you believe
that we can be data driven
and can you introduce some of the work
you've done with some of these priors in
deep learning
yeah so this is a very fundamental
debate clearly but i think it's not
all that black and white right so there
is a basically
at the core of machine learning there is
basically trade-offs
the the buy is variance trade-off for
instance it
clearly expresses this right the first
thing i want to say there is no machine
learning without assumptions it's just
basically
you have to interpolate between the dots
and to interpolate means that you have
to make assumptions on smoothness or
something like that so
the machine learning doesn't exist
without assumptions i think that's very
clear clearly it's a dial
right so you can have on the one hand
you can have problems with a huge amount
of data
it has to be available clearly and there
you can dial down your
inductive biases you can basically say
let that the data do
most of the work in some sense and let
me make my
prior assumptions quite minimal and with
minimal i think
i'm interested in a smooth mapping right
the mapping needs to be smooth like
that's a very minimal assumption
but the disadvantage of that is if you
don't put any prior assumptions
is that if you need to
take whatever you've learned into a new
domain
where this model wasn't learned it will
very quickly break down
because these prior assumptions will
help you
transfer from one domain to another
domain and
causality does play a big role here but
we can talk about that later
and then on the other hand there is
basically what everybody else in the
scientific community does which is
write down a model of the world which we
call a generative model which is
how do i imagine that the world that i'm
seeing in my measurement
apparatus could have been generated by
nature
and and that's that you can put a lot of
intuitive
knowledge there because you could think
the world is described by a pde
or some kind of generated model so so
people in our community often call this
probabilistic
programming models created by
probabilistic programs
or graphical models but they are highly
intuitive highly interpretable
and because they describe the generative
process they are
often also causal because you can think
of these variables and one causes the
other variable to happen etc
and because they are causal they really
generalize very well
which means that if i train you know
someone in one context let's say i learn
to drive
in the netherlands i'm driving on the
right side on the road i have particular
kind of
traffic signs etc so now i can take
whatever i've learned sort of these
rules or whatever
i've learned and now i can move to
another country where you drive on the
left-hand side of the road completely
different traffic signs and i can still
survive so this is typically something
that
the the the purely data-driven methods
have a much harder
time doing this sort of generalization
so i think this it's basically a
trade-off now it's it's the big question
in some sense over time
is can we simply take the data-driven
approach
and extend it all the way to agi
but there's people on one side of the
fence that are
claiming that this is possible right of
course we also need to
amplify computation right so we're just
going to build
faster and faster computers that can
digest
more and more data and at some point
we'll just
have agi emerge out of this kind of
process
and then on the other side which is
where the classical ai
sort of community which is no no that's
going to be ridiculous you will never be
able to do that you really need to
imbue these models with the structure of
the world which which i take
as how does physics work how does the
world work
can i tell you something about how data
really gets generated in this work
this will cut down the number of
parameters to learn dramatically
and it because i'm following causality
i can now basically generalize and
create agi
in this way and so it's going to be very
interesting how this is going to play
out and
now to be honest so i feel that i'm
slightly in the camp of
you really need to put generative
information into your models
but i've been continually surprised by
what's happening on the other side of
course a lot lots of my work is also on
the other side
in the sense that gpt3 you know is
completely 100
data driven and did we expect that it
would do so well
no so here's another big surprise right
and so that's i think that's the fun
part
but it kind of doesn't do well though it
doesn't have any reversibility so if you
ask it
how many feet fit in a shoe or we did
the example last week so
the corner table wants another beer it
doesn't know that the corner table is a
person because that's missing
information
we would fill in those gaps but it does
raise the question though of the
dichotomy between memorization and
compute
and the guy we were speaking to last
week just said that even if you had an
infinite
amount of memory and the the data's just
not there
you couldn't do it when you were
responding to rich sutton and you you
actually
spoke about all the different schools of
thought in machine learning so you said
compute driven versus knowledge
and model driven or data driven and
symbolic or statistical
and white box or black box and
generative and discriminative
the generative thing is fascinating
because our brains it's a bit like we've
got the matrix
we've got a simulation going on behind
the scenes haven't we we're always
thinking about all these potential
situations and possibly integrating
between them
yes i do agree that seems to be the real
trick for
intelligence at least in humans so our
ability
to generate the world at least at a
symbolic level
we don't generate like high resolution
videos in our brain but we do
generate objects and interactions
between objects and sort of how things
will play out
and this will also help us imagine
things like
what would have happened if i would have
done this so now i can play out this
alternative world
and say that was bad let me not do this
now so i think that is going to be a key
so that's a generative part of the
modeling because you can
generate you understand how the world
works the physics of the world works
and so you can generate possible futures
to me i feel that's going to be a really
important part of
intelligence and i do agree that it's
for me also very hard to see that
you can generate enough data to cover
all corner cases it's just very tough if
you do it in the wrong direction which
is the discriminative direction
but again i have been surprised by how
good these models really are and so you
say
gpt3 isn't very good maybe but it's a
receding
horizon right people may have not
thought this was true or bet on
something like gpt3 before it appeared
and then it appeared and people were
extremely impressed and then of course
some people
poke it and say but it doesn't
understand this and this and then
excitement goes away again a little bit
but
it is a bit of a receding horizon but i
have generally be very impressed also
with for instance the fact that we can
now generate
faces of people that that don't exist
we can create billions of faces that
don't exist on this planet and they look
absolutely realistic would i have
expected this no probably not
so no and then of course there's alphago
and things like this which we also
wouldn't have expected
right before it happens let me play a
bit of devil's advocate with respect to
building priors into models it it's
of course like some of the easiest
priors we can think of
are let's say translation invariants in
a cnn
you can also extend this to rotational
invariance and so on but if we look at a
true practical problem we say yes
it makes sense that there is rotational
invariance in
the world however on the imagenet data
set
like for a real practical problem the
sky is usually
up and the object is usually in the
center
it's not like to the side it's usually
in the center so
in a way it seems like if we actually
hit the true invariance that the world
adheres to it's certainly beneficial
but if we even slightly deviate if we
build in a different
invariance it seems like there is a
level of accuracy and if we want to get
past that
these invariants seems to be hurting do
you have a sense of
can it be counterproductive or when is
it counterproductive to build in such
invariances it's a very good question
and
so this goes to the point of the bias
variance decomposition again so
if you hit the right bias then it can be
beneficial
if you you know impose the wrong bias
then
it's going to hurt you and this is a
well-known trade-off so
of course the whole endeavor of machine
learning is
defining the right inductive biases
and leaving whatever you don't know to
the data
and then basically learning to focus
your models on
the data that you're actually seeing but
i agree if you put the wrong
inductive bias in it things will things
can actually
deteriorate now i should say here that
for the rotation invariance or
equivalence things are not as bad as you
might think so you said if you just have
slightly wrong inductive bias then
it hurts but that happens to be not so
much the case because
there's objects inside images
that do have if you turn a cat upside
down or a tree
upside down we still recognize it as a
tree in some sense and it does give you
a sort of
robustness to to certain transformations
on these objects that you would
otherwise maybe try to model by data
augmentation and stuff like that
now for the sky maybe you're right
that's similarly in the digits a six and
a nine
you know you will start to confuse a six
and a nine if you build in rotation
equivariance right and so there it will
actually hurt
but has been surprisingly robust
actually because basically because you
also cut down on the number of
parameters and by cutting down
on the number of parameters you will you
can actually
help the system generalize better so the
inductive bias doesn't have to be
perfect
and it can still help could we touch on
the dichotomy between the work you've
done and capsule networks for example
as well as the sample efficiency thing
for example with translational
equivariance
it means that you can you can move the
dog
and then the response map the dog has
moved as well and much of that is about
allowing neural networks to learn
patterns more easily because they can
map in every single layer
so with capsule networks that's still a
blank slate philosophy so you don't
explicitly say what the capsules are
whereas with with your approaches you
explicitly define the priors
with capsules it seems to be defined by
the data you give it so if you train a
capsule network on mnist data
it might inadvertently learn that one of
the capsules is how bendy the stroke
width is on the seven
or it might learn that there's a
rotation on the car because you've given
it lots of rotated versions of the same
car
but it seems quite arbitrary and the
algorithm is hideously inefficient
and what's much more exciting to me is
the kind of baked in prize that you've
designed
in the encoder stage so could you draw
the dots up between those two approaches
yeah i think you actually you said it
quite right so
one is a much more constrained system
than the other one but the
actual representations that we put in
our hidden layers
in both cases are very similar they are
stacks vectors and these vectors
transform
under certain operations so if i rotate
the input then there is some operation
on the stack of vectors which is they do
rotate in the x
y plane but they also permute in the
sort of
vector dimension and so that we tell it
very explicitly how to transform
we just say under these transformations
you have to transform like this and we
can do this because
these these geometric transformations
we know them that they appear in the
real world but so it's also constraining
because
there is many other transformations that
either we don't know precisely what the
mathematics for the representations
looks like or for instance like groups
that
are that are not compact maybe we have
looked at scaling
but it's already more of a stretch but
there's of course you can do many other
types of transformations that don't even
have to be groups that could be
other types of transformations like
lighting changes or whatever
if you wanted to incorporate all of
these you would have to build the
mathematical representation theory for
each of them and then it would actually
also explode
in a number of feature maps that you
would have to maintain and it's not a
very practical approach so
this works up to the transformation
groups that we understand and that are
everywhere around us
if we want to go beyond it then
basically something like capsules are
very nice because they tell you
well we'll just keep the abstract nature
of what we want which is
some stack of things that transform
in some way that we can vaguely specify
and then
we ask it to learn all these things and
we are actually ourselves also looking
at these sort of more relaxed notions of
equivariance where
we don't tell the system precisely how
to change we just want this to emerge
automatically
and again here the connection with the
brain is very interesting
in the brain we do seem to have all
sorts of filters which are related by
not only by rotations but all sorts of
other transformations
and they are topographically organized
so they are right the ones that are
related like a slightly rotated version
is sitting right next to the other one
in your brain
and so presumably your brain have
figured this out by just looking into
the world for a long time and it's
organized all these filters
that way and it's known that if you
if you prevent let's say a cat from
seeing then it will not come up with
this nice organization so you really
have to get that by
looking into the world a lot and that's
super fascinating and i think
that's where some of our research is is
being directed now can we learn from how
this happens in the brain
is there a connection between these
topographic maps and equivariance
somehow and and between capsules and all
of these things
and i believe that it is a good strategy
to
to take the general ideas agri variants
and then slowly relax it and let the
system learn more and more
uh so these capsule networks they've
been a bit hyped when
they were not really developed but named
first by
jeff hinton and he has this
concept or at least had it at the
beginning that it's some sort of
like an inverse rendering pipeline so
the sort of the capsule networks do
some sort of they take in the world and
they inverse render it
into these capsules how much do you
agree with that type of formulation it
seems what you've described is more of a
forward way of looking at capsules where
we have these invariances
yeah yeah so i don't i i very much agree
with this idea that you have smaller
things and they can be used in multiple
ways
but you have to align them in a
particular way so that they build
something at the higher level
and obviously you can invert that idea
too
in order to start at something very
abstract and then
generate certain things this way and
there is a lot of work now
actually going into equivariant
generative models for instance
equivalent flows a prime example is for
instance in physics and what's called
quantum chromodynamics there's
there's a theory that has a huge number
of symmetries called gauge symmetries
and if you transform these quarks
in a way in a particular way the physics
doesn't change you will have exactly the
same observations right but still you
need these
all these symmetries to to conveniently
describe this model
and so now when you generate you if you
want to generate
quark fields or something like this
right then gauge fields then
you can generate all these symmetries
and it's not very helpful because you
generate
one configuration but you then if you
generate all these
sort of equivalent things which are only
you know different by symmetry then you
haven't really done much so
understanding how to generate with this
equivariance in it is actually a big
topic of research
in many groups i think uh you know the
daniel razanda and
israel and deepmind has done a lot of
work and there's physicists at mit
and who doing work and we are with with
a group of
students and and physicists at amsterdam
we're also looking at these types of
questions
so that's i guess the inverse problem
where also what interference is playing
an
increasingly important role not many
people are working on
capsules i feel they've fallen out of
the favor of the public
because i don't know they're maybe hard
to implement
or they don't really work as advertised
let's say
do you have general thoughts about
capsule networks i think with many of
these things there is an underlying
intuition which is correct
so i haven't really worked myself in
trying to implement them
and so what's what you often see in this
field is that
there is an intuition about how
something should work
and often that's that is the correct
intuition especially when it's coming
from jeff hinton it is very likely to be
the correct intuition
now then there's the next step which is
how do you make something
practically implementable and these days
that means that you have to run it super
fast
right you have to be able to implement
it in gpus all these kinds of
constraints otherwise
you will be so much slower than just an
ordinary cnn
and you will basically not be able to
train as long as a cnn and
you cannot train as many parameters as
an ordinary cnn and you will not beat it
and if you don't have the bold numbers
hard to publish and so that might impede
progress in something like this but then
what happens is you wait
and then for five or ten years and then
the computers have become faster and
then people go back to these ideas and
then i think oh that was actually very
interesting let me try again
and then suddenly things start to work
now that's of course
the story of deep learning more
generally speaking
right because we had you know neural
networks like a long time ago
right in the 80s it was actually quite
popular to work on these things
but they didn't quite take off because
we didn't have the compute power
and maybe also not the data to really
train them well
and it's only when we took them out of
the the closet again and said hey man
this thing actually works if you throw a
whole bunch of gpus at it
that's when people then became popular
again and so you something that this
might well happen again with
with capsules or is something like
capsules in and about five to ten years
do you have an other than capsule
networks are there
things that right now we are not looking
back on but that would you know be
worthy of
of a revisit oh yeah that's very
tough but i'm personally looking at
things like ica
and topographic ica so i think there's
an interesting body of ideas there
of course i risk now to mow away the
grass before my own feet but okay let me
let me entertain that and then probably
marker random fields and things like
this
will probably make a comeback at some
point or graphical models more generally
will probably make a comeback or
maybe that integrated with deep learning
and and some people have already
attempted going in that direction energy
based models have made a comeback
already
so yeah it is often going back to older
ideas
and there's probably a lot more that
other people can sort of name
i do have a prediction maybe for the
future that people really haven't looked
at yet
in my opinion is going to be quantum
things so i think many people don't
actually know
understand the language of quantum
mechanics or mathematics
and i do think that first of all that
language is very interesting it's a bit
different than our normal probabilities
it's like square roots of probabilities
and with the advent of quantum computers
which at some point will come
we as a community will have to dive into
that
and maybe make it part of our curriculum
in
university and then i think that will
become that will start to
boom could i just quickly introduce
before we get to quantum
i don't know if you read sarah hooker's
the hardware lottery paper
and this is fascinating for you of
course working at qualcomm but
her idea was that there are certain
things that cause inertia or friction in
the marketplace of ideas so
is it a meritocracy of ideas or do the
previous kind of hardware decisions and
hardware landscape
does it enslave us you know ideas
succeeded they're compatible with the
hardware and the software at the time
and this is what she called
a hardware lottery and she says the
machine learning community is
exceptional because the pace of
innovation is so fast
it's not like in the hardware world
which you all know so well where it
costs so much money to develop new
hardware and the cost of being scooped
is so high
but i wanted to just come at this from i
don't know
how you see this right so with capsule
networks the reason they're so slow is
because it's a kind of sequential
computing paradigm and
no amount of hardware is going to solve
that but there are
entirely different paradigms of hardware
like quantum which could potentially
change the game but how much could they
change the game is there still some
limit on it
there's always a limit clearly but i
think the the situation is maybe
slightly more subtle which is that
working in a hardware company i can also
see the other side of the coin a little
bit
so there is also a race in the hardware
companies to build
asic designs like which is specialized
hardware
to run the latest and the greatest
machine learning algorithms which are
being developed
so it's not just which machine learning
algorithms work well
on the current hardware that us being
enslaved to the hardware there is
actually a feedback which
where now the companies are trying to
build asic
to first of all run the convolutions
very efficiently
and soon we'll have probably
transformers
run very efficiently and so that's the
fascinating thing of course
it's hard to get your paper published
perhaps if if you're ahead of the game
too much which i see a little bit in the
machine learning community
which is if you look at the papers which
are published in the physics community
they work with
images of four by four pixels that's
what they can do
because otherwise you need a quantum
computer obviously to run your algorithm
and it's being looked down upon a lot by
the machine learners
basically saying what do we you know why
is that interesting
and i do feel very strongly that as a
field we need to open up so we we should
value original ideas much more than we
currently do
and i don't know you know you can
probably have a whole conversation on
where this is coming from
i think the reviewing in our community
is far too
grumpy i think people if it's not
completely finished polished paper then
you know they'll find a hole
somewhere and they start pushing on it
and i think you should look also at the
sort of more
holistic how original is this idea right
can you be excited about the originality
and the creativity of the idea that went
into that and
trust that maybe it takes the community
a couple of years to further develop
this
and and and some things will die and
that's fine but let all these flowers
grow in a way
and yeah so i i do feel a little bit
that sometimes is a bit
negative and i and and that's maybe
where some of their friction is coming
from
that yeah just on that it's fascinating
we're talking to kenneth stanley on
monday and he wrote a book
greatness can't be planned and his big
thing is exactly what you've just said
that we have this
convergent behavior in so many of our
systems whether it's science or academia
and it's because of this objective
obsession so we all want
to monotonically increase our objectives
and what we should be is treasure
hunters
yes science should be about exploration
not exploitation
exploitation is one step away you
already know how to build the bridge
we don't seem to have this paradigm at
the moment even
when you submit your paper to be
reviewed there's a consensus mechanism
isn't there because
you need to have multiple accepts from
people and science
advances one funeral at a time yes do
you think this is a huge problem
yeah i think it is a big problem but i
think also we will probably
i think it's a big problem because it
will hold us back and it will also hold
very brilliant students back so what do
i advise my students now
i advise them to have a mixed model a
mixed sort of
policy which says on the one hand you
work on some papers which are
easy to score on things that are very
popular in the community
and then on the other hand you work on
things which might be you know
huge innovations that are much more
uncertain they might fail but then there
might also be really
big innovations and that way you get
your papers and you can become famous
but at least also you work on things
which are highly risky but in fact
it's a bit cynical to have to do that it
would be much nicer if there would be
much more appreciation for
just originality and but i do also
believe there is a solution to this so i
think
we are in a sort of a local minimum as a
community in this sense but i think
there's a way out and one way out
which is basically and this has been
already proposed long time ago i think
yamacon and yarsha benjamin were also
talking about this and we are actually
trying to implement this for a beijing
deep learning workshop
is to sort of to throw papers on the
archive
and not necessarily submit to
conferences and to have a
open reviewing of that and to
give people reputation in dc so if you
do
if you give a good review you can
publish your own review or
stated in your cv and people can rate
your review
and if you do poor reviews you'll get
horrible ratings and then your
reputation will come down
so there is some kind of way that you
can probably design is that people are
incentivized to give good reviews and to
actually
use these reviews as a half a paper that
you can
also be proud of and then good things
will come up right they will at some
point people will point to interesting
ideas
maybe we need some kind of recommender
to make sure it's a bit
unbiased in the sense that it's not only
the famous people that will get their
papers exposed but also
less famous people so we need to have
sort of maybe build a recommender around
something like that
every so now and then a conference comes
by and it sort of harvests
in this field of sort of papers let's
say that one they're all reviewed they
have great reviews
i'll take one or two more reviews
anonymously
and i'll then publish and then i invite
you to present your paper in our
conference
that to me sounds like a much more
natural way to proceed i also
find it very demotivating for my
students who have these ideas maybe this
is the worst part so you're a student
you're working on this thing which is
not completely mainstream
and then you get rejected two or three
times from a conference right
this is so demotivating for a student to
then continue right at this case
at least you just you push this on the
archive and you engage with the
community around your paper
and that's a much more it's much less
demotivating than these constant
rejections
from the big prizes right the nurif's
paper or the html paper that everybody
wants
zeitgeist the idea at the moment a lot
of people are talking about this how can
we improve peer review
like in every field people are moving
towards this open review model
but collectively as a research community
we don't really have the collaboration
tools at this point in time to
take advantage of it open review is
willing to implement this actually so
yeah i think it will happen
it's a good system to pivot back into
new ideas and
sort of exciting concepts that are
coming out machine learning at the
moment
you mentioned quantum computing is this
paradigm that's
really critical that's not really well
understood by the machine learning
community
would you be able to give our listeners
like the five-minute spiel about quantum
probability how it differs from the
probabilities that we're used to
yeah so you can think of quantum
mechanics as another
theory of statistics in some sense right
so in
ai for everything we can't totally
observe we write down probabilities of
things happening
but of course underlying there is
processes but we just don't observe
everything and so we
describe it by probability now on
quantum mechanics it's very similar to
taking the square root of a negative
number in some sense it's like you
let me put another way so it's very much
like taking the square root of a
probability
which can actually become negative so
minus one squared is one
right okay or let's say -2 squared is 4
4 is your probability and -2
could be your quantum amplitude this
thing can be negative
and the bizarre thing is that if you
describe a system by
these quantum amplitude these square
roots then
they can cancel which is this this is
the counterintuitive part which is
you can have a probability for an event
or an amplitude for an event and then
for
you have an amplitude for another event
and you would think that if there's two
probabilities for that event to happen
then
the probability that events should grow
but in quantum mechanics they can cancel
and then the probability is suddenly
zero that the event happens
so this seems bizarre but nature has
chosen this theory of statistics anyway
and so it behooves us to look into this
more so first
question is can you write down
maybe even normal classical problems
more conveniently
in this quantum statistics and here i
always remind myself when i first learn
complex numbers so when you learn to
solve the
damped oscillator equation you can do it
in a complicated way
or you can go to complex numbers and
then suddenly it gets very
easy to do it and so you can imagine
that
there is things to compute in classical
statistics that are actually either
shortcuts by using quantum mechanics
somehow
and and so the first thing that we've
tried to do with quantum mechanics in
deep learning is to say
can we just design an architecture
that would be naturally a natural fit to
this quantum mechanical description
of the world but we still want to be
able to run it
on a classical computer we just want to
describe this
we just want to harvest these new
degrees of freedom that we have from
quantum mechanics
and so that was a paper that we recently
pushed on the archive which is a
quantum deformed neural networks which
we basically first say okay what if we
would
take a normal neural net and implement
it on a quantum computer and then we
slightly deform it
into something where states get
entangled and this entanglement is
another
strange as a phenomenon in in quantum
mechanics where you can create
states which you cannot really create
classically superpositions of states
and and so by doing it in this
particular way we could still run it
efficiently on a classical computer but
it's just a very different beast than a
normal neural network so that's already
to me very interesting
and then of course the big prize the big
bonus is that if you
adhere to this way of describing what's
happening is that there is the
opportunity to be able to run things
very efficiently on a quantum computer
so now you can design
your neural network in such a way that
classically actually it will be very
hard
to simulate it but then on a quantum
computer you could potentially simulate
it
very efficiently and and of course we
don't have quantum computers so it's
very hard to
actually prove your point but that also
what makes it somewhat
exciting in that paper specifically you
make you make lots of references and
connections to
the bayesian way of doing machine
learning could you
what's the connection there because it
seems different both are i
agree both are statistics and you
already mentioned the square roots of
probabilities
but how do you connect the sort of
uncertainty quantification
in the bayesian way with how
particles move quantum mechanics is not
necessarily about particles so
you can just you can write quantum
mechanics
on just like states you can just write
down as
a number of classical states like i say
a sequence
of zeros and ones and there's an
exponential number of these states
and then you can say classically i can
only be in one of these states but in
quantum mechanics i can be in any
linear combination of these states which
is a bigger space
now what we did in that paper was to say
we can
treat both the world state as well as
the parameter
state as a quantum we describe it by a
quantum wave function
and then we entangle these different
states which is similar to saying that i
take my state
classical state x i multiply it by a
matrix of parameters and i get a new
state
out so here the analogy would be i have
my
quantum superposition of classical
states i have a quantum superposition of
parameter states and then there are some
process where we get
get entangled together and then i do a
measurement
which is now a function of both the
parameters as well as the
inputs and you train it to give you
measurements that with high probability
give you the answer that you want so
that would be the training process
now there is actually a very precise way
in which you can relate
bayesian posterior inference in quantum
mechanics but
that's a fairly technical story but
there is a using density matrices there
is a fairly precise way in which you can
say i have a
state described by a density matrix and
if i do a measurement i condition on
something and i renormalize and stuff
like that so
that's possible so there are two things
like first of all
the quantum neural network formulation
can be very slow on a classic computer
but fast on a quantum computer
on the other hand people do run like
bayesian inference
on classical computers what makes the
quantum neural networks that much harder
to compute
yeah it's this entanglement issue so in
so
but classically i agree there is an
analogy in classical
uh statistics where this looks very
similar which is for instance
if i have a exponentially large state
space
and i write down a probability
distribution over all of these possible
states
where they have a number a positive
number that sums to one for each one of
these exponentially large states and if
i ask you now compute an average of a
function
over this probability distribution you
can't do it because there's an
exponentially large number of things
that you would have to sum
and so we have ways to deal with it
which is sampling from these
distributions or variational
approximations
in any way we have to approximate this
state of affairs
now in quantum that's it's fairly
similar so there's you you face it
a similar exponential problem and you
can also do
approximations to get around that and
but the interesting part is that in
quantum mechanics
you can for instance do a measurement
and and a measurement
is something that you know that is
against a physical thing and it's not
very hard to do but it will be an
operation which looks like sampling
something down to a particular classical
state again
and it does look like the sampling
operation that we do in
sort of artificially in probability
theory
but it's also true that quantum
computers can in principle compute
things that classical computers can't
compute
and they can they can actually compute
it much faster whether that actually
maps to the things that we are
interested in is not so clear so that's
it's not at all clear right now that we
will actually build quantum
neural networks that are
generalizing a lot better on classical
problems
right if you want to do classical
predictions does it actually help to
build
a a neural network that can run
efficiently on a quantum computer that
can do these predictions
much better that's not known but that's
what makes it exciting in my opinion
because you can try to do it
now there's also functions that you
can't even
do classically you have to do quantum
mechanically but i don't know how
relevant
they are for ai fascinating can we
conceivably say that at least one
let's say applications or way for these
neural
networks or for the quantum neural
networks to come in
is in in the place where right now we
have these
renormalization problems let's say uh
big word embeddings
or yeah as you mentioned things like
variational inference any anywhere where
you have a partition function
that you let's say have to sample to
compute
now we potentially introduce this new
way of doing this
yes i would say that is a different set
of problems so there is
some sampling algorithms which can be
sped up
by quantum sampling algorithms but i
think the maximum speed up is like
a square root so it's not insignificant
but it's also not exponential
okay right so you can do something in
square root time of what a normal
classical computer could do
and then there's these very interesting
stories where
people thought that they could do things
much faster on a quantum computer but
then somebody
thought really hard about it and they
then invented actually a quantum
inspired
classical random algorithm which would
do about
the same speed or close the close
at least so it's very uncertain
precisely what we can speed up
but that's what makes it interesting
right it's
especially if you can predict what's
going to happen in some sense it's just
a matter of executing
right but if you don't know if they're
what they're what the low-hanging fruit
is and if there is low-hanging fruit and
what the possible benefits and
benefits are the possible bonus that you
can get by doing these things
then it gets really interesting in my
opinion amazing
now might be a good time to talk about
your other paper that's just come out
max which is probabilistic
numeric convolution on your networks and
this was also with mark finzee who we
just discovered this morning
just brought out a really interesting
paper about equivariance on light groups
so that might be a
potential digression later but this
works really fascinating because it's in
the setting of irregularly sampled data
and we use these
gaussian processes to represent that and
we can continuously interpolate between
them
in this convolutional setting absolutely
fascinating could you give us the
the elevator pitch yeah first let me say
again
that mark finchy was an intern at
qualcomm
and and roberto bondison was is the
other person who was also working with
me on the quantum
stuff so those are my collaborators in
this project and of course mark
did the bulk of the work for this paper
so he should deserve
much of the credit for it but here's the
observation that we had the observation
is when we write down a a deep learning
algorithm let's say on the foreign image
then we sort of treat the image as
pixels and we think that's the real
signal that we
are looking at but you can also ask
yourself what if i
remove every second pixel now i actually
have a very different neural network but
should i have a very different neural
network or what if the pixels are
actually quite randomly
distributed in the plane with just some
random places where i do measurements
maybe more on the left upper corner and
and fewer on the left lower corner
the predictor should behave in a certain
consistent way
and so of course then you come to
realize that really what you're doing
with the pixel grid is sampling and
underlying continuous signal
so then we just started thinking how do
you best deal with this so
how do you how can you build this in and
so
there's a very interesting tool which is
called the gaussian process
it basically interpolates between dots
but in places where you don't have a lot
of data
you create uncertainty because you don't
know what the real signal is so you
basically get some kind of
interval which says okay i think the
signal is somewhere in this interval
with
95 cert you know certainty but i don't
know precisely where
now the mean function is a smooth
actual continuous function and then the
next step will say okay what what does
it mean to do a convolution
on this space this is the new gaussian
process interpolated space
and what we found is that the most
interesting way to describe that
is by looking at it as a partial
differential equation
and so this ties back into another
really interesting line at work which
was started by
david duvano and authors on thinking of
a neural network as
od as an ordinary differential equation
so
here we're talking about a pde basically
because we have spatial
extent and so we are looking at sort of
derivatives and second order derivatives
in
in the plane basically which which we
apply
on the continuous function so this is
literally what people do when they
solve a pde is that they have some
operator which is
consists of derivatives which they apply
to the function
and then they have a time component
which evolves this thing
forward in time basically and it turns
out that's a very natural way to
describe a convolution
you can also add symmetries in a very
natural way by looking at that
operator that sort of moves things
forward and making sure it's invariant
under certain
transformations we had a bit of trouble
really handling the non-linearity that
falls
that happens then so we had to then
project it back onto something that
would then
again easily handle by a gaussian
process etc so we had to do some work
there
but in the end this thing was now
actually very general and interesting
tool which is
apply a gaussian process apply pde apply
non-linearity
repeat and then in the end collect all
your information and make a prediction
and it so some of the benefits are now
that first of all of course you cannot
work on
a unstructured set of points doesn't
have to be a grid
and you can even learn the positions of
those points so you can now direct
the observations in places where you
really need to do
observations in order to improve your
prediction so it basically becomes
a numerical integration procedure where
you can learn where to move your
integration points
and what i also found very fascinating
is that
this same paradigm can be mapped on
again onto a quantum
paradigm where you can think of that pde
that evolves now as a schrodinger
equation that sort of
evolves like a a wave function so it
maps very nicely also again to a quantum
problem and that's what we are working
on now something that's really
fascinating that keeps coming up again
and again in these sorts of research
programs
is the matrix exponential like it's our
connection to groups and algebras or
like group representations and algebras
and of course we use it to evolve our
odes and pves
i guess as a physicist you've probably
got a deeper appreciation of this
particular object
but it's something that's still quite
alien to a lot of people i know
that work in applied machine learning
what's the significance of the matrix
exponential why does it connect
all these really fundamental objects to
things like
lead groups and stuff like that yeah so
it's interesting that we
actually just got a paper accepted in
nureps on this and it's called the
convolution exponential and you can look
it up and emil
bomb is the main author and generator of
that idea
and yeah so it i guess it because it is
the solution to the ode or the pde right
so
if you write down something that's very
fundamental that is
a first order differential equation
which is d
dt the derivative with respect to t of a
state
is some operator times that state then
the solution of that thing will be
the state over time is the matrix
exponential
times t times the state so that's i
think where it comes from
and so one other way to look at it is
that
in physics it's called the greens
function so it's it's basically the
solution to this ode so
you can think of a neural net
as basically we tend to describe it as a
discrete
you know map from one point to another
point but if you think of it as a
continuous process which is what we
learned from the
ode description of a neural net if you
think of it
as a continuous process then it's really
you can just think of that convolution
this map you can just think of it
as the matrix exponential solution to
this to this ode
in math literacy you call this the
greens function so you can think of a
convolution basically as the greens
function
of a partial differential equation i
think that's where the
why this feels like a very fundamental
object in some sense
so in in a talk you gave recently on the
future
of graph neural networks you were
talking about a number of
ideas from physics that hadn't really
made it into machine learning
among them things like renormalization
chaos and holography
would you care to unpack these ideas a
little bit and tell us where you see
the future is in these ideas yeah so the
reason i mention these because um i
think there's a lot of really cool ideas
in physics which are still remain
unexplored
but there is more and more physicists
who are moving into the field and some
of these ideas are actually you know
being worked out as we speak so i
recently saw
about two papers on renormalization so
randomization
is something in in physics which
basically you start with
a system with a whole lot of degrees of
freedom like say particles moving around
or something like this
and then you coarse grain the system
slowly
and what means is that by coarse
graining you
zoom out and you build an effective
theory of the underlying theory in the
same sense as thermodynamics is an
effective theory of statistical
mechanics
where basically all the particles are
now removed but you now have an
effective sort of description of your
world
this is the same as what happens in
neural nets right the neural nets we
talk about pixels at the bottom layer
and maybe edge detectors and things at
the very top of it we're talking about
objects and relations between objects
which are aggregated
emergent properties from this neural net
and ideas from
randomization theory might very nicely
apply
to this particular problem and indeed
have already been applied with some
success
the other one which you mentioned was
chaos and i think there is a very nice
connection actually with chaos theory
going back to
work i did long time ago which i called
herding
in particular you can think of sampling
from a particular distribution
you can do it either by the typical way
is first of all you can think of it as a
dynamical system as a stochastic
dynamical system
and you think of it as there's a you're
at a particular point and then
you propose to go somewhere and then you
accept or reject a particular point
and as you jump through the space and
you collect your
the points that you jumped to then you
look at that
collection and that collection should
then actually distribute according to
the probability distribution
that you're sampling from now that's a
stochastic process but if you think very
hard about that
in fact it's a deterministic process
even if you try to make it stochastic
and the reason is that every time you
know you're doing a whole bunch of
calculations
and so now and then you call a random
number generator
but the random number generator really
is a pseudo-random number generator it
is also a deterministic calculation that
you're doing
so the whole thing end-to-end is just a
deterministic calculation
but because you're calling the pseudo
random number generated it looks very
stochastic
but truly it is a chaotic process and so
you should really be able to describe
this system by
chaos theory and the theory of nonlinear
dynamical systems
now what i've been working on with my
postdoc and roberto
because it's called kahil what we've
been working on is thinking about
let's make it a little bit less chaotic
so let's make this actually a
deterministic system which is
maybe at the edge of chaos and again
this is one of these very deep questions
that's in my head so i think
so there's there is something very
interesting and deep here which is
if you do if you try to do a computation
on the one hand you want to store
information things that you've
calculated
and for that things need to be stable on
the other hand you want to
transform information because that's
what a calculation is right
and so there you want to be in this sort
of more chaotic domain
and it turns out that the best place to
be is at the edge of two things right
you can go to the right a little bit and
be more
stable and go to the left a little bit
and you can transform things
and compute things and so i also think
that when you're trying to sample or in
you know
you sampling can be equated with
learning if you're basing about things
because
in learning is basically sampling from
the posterior distribution and that's
same as learning you can if you can
design
samplers that are not completely chaotic
as the ones that we described now but
they're more structured and less chaotic
and more deterministic moving through
the space
you can learn a lot faster and i find
that and then you can actually start to
map it on to sort of complexity theory
notions if you think of this sampling
from a discrete set of
states what kind of properties do the
sequences that i generate have
what is the entropy of the sequences
that i'm generating for instance
or what kind of substructures is it for
instance going to be
periodic or are there periodic
substructures inside of it or all these
things and these are
studied by the theory of chaos and
nonlinear dynamical systems so
connecting these two fields feels to me
like a very fundamental thing to try and
do
and some people have tried a few things
people have looked at well
if you look at a neural net there's an
iterated map you map things to hidden
layers
and if you think of that iterated map
and think of it as
is that map chaotic being on the edge of
chaos
is the best thing you shouldn't be
completely
non-movable because then everything you
put in is going to be mapped to the same
point very uninteresting
you also shouldn't be super chaotic
because of whatever you put in you're
going to some random point in space and
that's not very predictive
so you need to be at this intersection
space between chaos and non-chaos and
then you can do interesting computations
so this is the same idea right so to me
that's exciting because now suddenly a
whole field
of exciting mathematics is cracked open
and you can start to
use all these tools in machine learning
awesome thank you very fantastic
now might be a good time to go over to
reddit we asked reddit for
questions and the top rated question is
by
tsa hi max when will you be changing
your last name to pooling
so actually there is a paper that a
colleague of mine
wrote and i think they had an operator
which they called
instead of pooling you could you could
do uh a
welding operator so and instead of
changing my name
i i propose that we just change the
operators that we use and change to
willing operators
that's wonderful in the thread on reddit
there were a few variations as well so
maybe max power
and someone asserted that pooling is
your brother
but anyway red portal says the
conventional approach for
analyzing continuous convolution would
be fourier analysis
what was the rationale behind
investigating continuous convolutions
using probabilistic numerics
that's a good question so to me fourier
analysis
it it's true that you can i guess i
could still do a fourier analysis right
because the gaussian process
you can decompose in terms of its
fourier waves and then it's the
primal versus the dual view of uh sort
of any sort of kernel method so
i could certainly go to the fourier
domain and do my calculations in the
fourier domain
in quantum mechanics this is just
another basis you just think of this as
another basis
you know not only quantum mechanics in
any signal processing sense
and it's true that a convolution is
easier there because just multiplication
on the other hand convolutions are very
efficient
in modern software packages for
gpus so sometimes it's also
not necessarily faster to do that but
it's a good suggestion and
maybe something nice happens when you go
to fourier space and
i just didn't explore that fantastic
we've also got jimmy the ant lion says
hi max
i notice your co-authors come from a
physics background can you explain why
there are so many ex-physicists in deep
learning
yeah so that's interesting i think
there's just a lot of physicists
and a fraction of those physicists is
looking for
other for greener pastures and i myself
on one of those that i was looking for
greener pastures
and they bring a really good toolbox so
if you've done physics you're you have
just
a very good mathematical toolbox but
also very good intuition about
pdes and how the world works and
symmetries and all these kind of things
you bring
and i think in some sense physics is
also a bit of a
container right if you do physics you
can still do anything else afterwards in
some sense
and i think just there's just people who
are naturally interested in ai
of course ai became very popular at some
point and so you have automatically
people flock into that
into that field but yeah in general
they're smart people
so i guess it's nice to work with them
maybe just
circle back and and close the loop to
the beginning and we were talking about
the research community and kind of the
machine learning research field i i
loved what you
suggested and as i understand this is
not fully your suggestion but
the suggestion of let's say having a
more
open review kind of system where a
review could be as powerful as a paper
itself
i've been screaming for this for a few
years now
and could i ask if you if you ever have
the chance to propagate this
what do you think of the idea of having
a continuous research
like this paper notion that we have now
i think it's so outdated
and once my paper is published i have no
incentive to update that thing
what if we do research in in this much
more continuous way and then there's
comments and
then in response to the comments
everything changes and so on
yeah no it's very good point it's it's
so this is indeed
exactly part of this idea that we are
trying open review to implement
yeah but it's the idea is that in open
review you have a conversation with your
reviewers
and it's nice if the reviewers are not
anonymous they're just you just have
your conversation and other people can
even contribute
to the project in a more open sciency
way but it is also nice and now and then
to present your work and so
that's why i say so now and then a
a conference might come in and harvest
papers and just invite people to present
their work in a sort of slightly more
formal way and maybe
put a stamp of approval on it and say
this conference has published or
this particular paper with some
independent reviews and we think it's a
great paper and so you get that stamp so
it and i guess there should also be a
way to close off a particular project to
move on to a new project but
i also have the same view as you have
as this being a far more continuous
process where
you know if you didn't get picked this
time next time somebody some conference
will come by and
and pick you out it's much more like a
marketplace where ideas go around
conferences come in and ask you to
publish things and it's just
you then present it and then you can
just continue with your research or stop
it and
go to a new piece of work or something
like this so yeah i i share that vision
basically
that's it's amazing i'm continuously
amazed when i read
these old papers from let's say schmidt
uber and like the first rl papers that
just came up with a bit of an idea and
then they had a bit of toy data and
right and that's a paper and
and it's cool do you have any do you
have any kind of
thoughts about or recommendations for
the new generation of researchers that
are now flooding the fields
of how can we get to a better field what
kind of
tips would you give the yeah we i think
we really need to disrupt
the field a little bit and so i think we
i think the new
i think it's particularly tough for new
researchers
because it's the acceptance rates for
these conferences are very low and
it it feels like much of your future
career depends on getting papers in
there and it's a fairly random process
as well so i think we just need to
disrupt the field and there's enough
people
with influence who want that so it's
just a matter of actually executing on
it and so that's
what we do it now for the bayesian deep
learning
workshop that we are organizing this we
want this to be
a an off split from neribs
it was very popular workshop there and
somehow we got rejected
this year and we thought okay we'll just
do it ourselves we do have
actually a meet-up but then next year we
want to be our stand-alone
conference but for that conference we
want to implement this plan and so we
are working with open review to actually
implement this for us and jaren galla is
working hard
to try to actually roll this out and we
talk to joshua banjo about it and he's
very supportive and there's a whole lot
of people who are supportive about it
but
so if this can help to make this a
popular model then that will be a
fantastic result of this interview
but i think people should just push for
it and just say okay i'm just fed up
with the current way of doing things we
should really change things
and just shout out and say this is what
we want and let's go for it
awesome amazing professor max welling
it's been an absolute honor and a
pleasure to have you on the show
thank you so much for joining us today
it was great with the three of you
asking questions that works really well
fantastic thank you so much thank you
amazing it was good the questions were
really fantastic actually and i've never
done this with the three of you but
having a team of three people
asking questions is really it's a good
idea and of course you're really smart
people in knowing what you're talking
about so that went really well i think
needs three brains to match yours
[Laughter]
anyway i really hope you've enjoyed the
show today this has been such a special
episode for us because max welling is is
literally one
one of my heroes so um anyway remember
to like
comment and subscribe we love reading
your comments we we really do actually
we're getting
so many amazing comments in the comment
section so keep them coming
and uh we will see you back
next week